[Music]
welcome back to the next episode of
what's up prof
hello walter good day how are you doing
uh the same as yesterday and the day
before i'm actually quite fine
that's good i'm glad let's open with a
word of prayer
our heavenly father we thank you again
that we can get together
lord would you please enlighten our
minds once again
and help us discern the truth from the
error in jesus name
amen so we
gonna answer a few questions again
question time yes um
i'll get right into it first question
that we have
is where did cain get his wife
well that is not something that is too
complicated
there was one pair that was created and
that was adam and eve
and they were perfect their genetic
system was
immaculate there was no fault in it
whatsoever so
they had children and they had
many children we don't know how many we
know of
a few of them but we don't know about
the rest so they had sons and daughters
now they were probably over 900 years
old when they died
and let's say if we take that in today's
term
then they should have been fertile
in terms of producing children to at
least
400 if not 500 years
so how many children did eve have we
don't know but she had
many daughters and many sons
and because there were no genetic
aberrations whatsoever
there was no problem if one married his
sister
so kane married his sister
and this was allowed to continue in the
early generations
eventually because of the fall genetic
aberrations came in
and there were restrictions placed if
you go up to the time of abraham
abraham still married his half-sister
yes
so that was still perfectly permissible
wasn't the same
both parents weren't the same but one of
them was the same
and then as you carry on eventually the
restrictions become greater and you
shouldn't
marry within the very close confines of
the family
because of the genetic aberrations but
in the early
ones there were no genetic aberrations
so i assume
that the wife that cain married was the
rebellious one
and she sympathized with him and when
cain
was banished she says well if he goes i
go
[Music]
and that is where the line of cane
started
so the early first children
married their siblings should a
christian date or marry a non-christian
whoa you don't know
ask this one right okay
should a christian date or marry a
non-christian
now this is a a very serious issue
and the answer is not one
that is very simple
but let's just look at some bible verses
second corinthians 6 14 says be ye
not unequally yoke together with
unbelievers
for what fellowship has righteousness
with unrighteousness and what communion
has
light with darkness so the bible
clearly tells us that we should not be
yoked together
with unbelievers now if you're married
then you yoke together now there was a
problem from the beginning
and that's where the system went wrong
because right in the beginning in the
bible it says
and the sons of god saw that the
daughters of men
were beautiful and they started marrying
them so this
is the line that followed the line of
sith
and the line of cain and
the line of cain they were the daughters
of men
and the line of sith those were the sons
of god
because everybody who was aligned with
with the truth and with god they were
the sons of god but eventually
they went shopping in the malls of those
days and saw
the daughters of men are rather
beautiful and started marrying them
and that's where things went wrong yeah
you can go through the history of the
bible what happened to solomon
eventually exactly the same thing down
the same route
he went down the same road and it led to
a terrible terrible decline in the
spirituality of the whole nation
so it is never a good thing to be
unequally yoked now we know that it does
happen
but biblically it is
not recommended in fact if you take the
the text as it reads it is forbidden
yes now we do many things that are
forbidden in this world
and men are subject to human weakness
and i assume the woman at the well who
had five
men and the one that she was living with
was not a husband was also not doing the
will of god but god had compassion on
her
so if you read the bible it is strictly
forbidden
if you read the spirit of prophecy it is
strictly forbidden
but it does happen now what does happen
when it when it happens well there's
another verse in the bible which is 1
corinthians 7
14 which is a very interesting verse
it says for the unbelieving husband is
sanctified
by the wife
this this of course obviously means
a a wife that is in the faith
yes because can something
clean come out of something unclean and
the answer in the bible is also clear
no for the unbelieving husband is
sanctified by
the wife so we could actually put a
word in there believing wife
and the unbelieving wife is sanctified
by the husband
or the believing husband as it were else
were your children unclean but now they
are holy
so the bible makes provision for the
fact that it does happen
so if an unbelieving husband
is married to a believing wife that
their children
will be considered clean on the basis
that either the wife or the husband or
in the faith
but it's safer to say if you have a
choice
before then follow the first then you
follow the first one
if it does happen and an unbelieving
husband or wife marries an unbelieving
or believing
uh partner then you will have conflict
in that marriage and
it depends how deep that conflict runs
and how much tolerance there is
so then in that case
stays married and prays
and through the example that the
believing wife or the believing husband
sits in the household tries to win the
other one
over and if the other one refuses to be
brought over
then you will have to sit with that
situation so better
to avoid the situation in the first
place
yes so that is the answer it's not a
very
pleasing answer to most but that is what
the bible teaches
i mean what is the meaning of the
biblical feasts
should we still keep the biblical feasts
now there's a lot of contention on that
issue ryan yes
and there's a lot of history attached to
it
and the feasts are of course types
pointing to a greater reality
so i think we should we should spend a
little time on this one and perhaps just
go through a few points
i think that will be good and to see how
this one
can be applied in the time that we are
living it
so the question is to feast or not to
feast
and depending who you talk to you will
get a particular opinion yes
if we go through the to the spirit of
prophecy
it tells us that in a special sense
seventh-day adventists have been set in
the world
as watchmen and light-bearers
to them has been entrusted the last
warning for a perishing world on them is
shining wonderful light from the word of
god
they have been given a work of the most
solemn import
the proclamation of the first second
and third angel's messages
there is no other work of so great
importance they too
are to allow nothing else to absorb
their attention
now we've been doing that for a whole
year now
and prior to that for numerous years
but what is the message that has to go
to the world
the first the second and the third
angels messages
now we know that the first angel's
message
is the entire gospel virtually yes
because it says i saw another angel
flying in the midst of heaven having the
everlasting gospel to proclaim
and then it says you must worship god
who is the creator of all things
and then the second angel's message
goes to those who refuse the fullness
of this message and then the third
angel's message
deals with obedience to god's
requirements
and when you are obedient to his
then you accept the justification that
comes from him
in other words the obedience that you
have
is flowing out of your acceptance
of the grace that god has given you it's
not a means to salvation it's a
consequence of salvation
so that is the job are we supposed to
go into the world and preach a message
that you have to believe this that and
the other or you have to believe in the
feasts or you
have to believe in whatever message
there
is that detracts from the proclamation
of this what is the center of your
message
is the point that i'm making this should
be the center of your message
the three angels messages and
what you believe about the feasts is
always secondary to this
in acts chapter 15 we read and certain
men which came down from judea
taught the brethren and said except you
be
circumcised after the manner of moses
you cannot be saved
and here they taught that a ceremonial
law
was essential to salvation
because they said if you're not
circumcised you cannot be saved
so the question is are the feasts
ceremonial
or they're not ceremonial that's the
issue right
okay circumcision was obviously
ceremonial because it pointed
to the circumcision of the heart
acts chapter 15 verse 2 says when
therefore paul
and barnabas had no small dissension
and disputation with them so was it a
hot issue yes
so these issues can be very hot
now this is quite a euphemism
because when it says they had no small
dissension what does that mean it was a
big decision it was a big issue
so some people make very big issues
out of out of things like these and they
will make
it salvational if you don't understand
it like
i understand it you will
not go to heaven okay
and they determined that paul and
barnabas and certain
other of them should go up to jerusalem
unto the apostles and elders about this
question so it became so heated that
not even the authority of paul and
barnabas was trusted by these people
do we have similar circumstances today
definitely
we have we have many issues
that are raging even within our own
ranks
whether you're talking about the feast
issue
whether you're talking about the trinity
there are so many things that seem to be
absolutely salvational to many people
we want to do justice to it we don't
want to be judgmental
but we need to look at the issue right
correct
we read on but there rose up certain of
the sect of the pharisees
which believed saying that it was
needful to circumcise them and to
command them to keep
the law of moses so it wasn't only
circumcision it was the entire law of
moses
now the law of moses was
ceremonial yes it was the ceremonial law
so they included the entire and
ceremonial law in this issue and said
well
nothing has changed we must still keep
them as they were all the laws yeah
ceremonial and moral
and so they had a gathering and it's a
very
important gathering it was like a
general conference gathering
and the apostles and the elders came
together for to consider this matter
and when there had been much disputing
and so did they resolve this issue
easily no
no did everybody agree on it no
there was much disputing so there were
obviously two sides to the story right
peter rose up and said unto them men and
brethren
you know how that a good while ago
god made choice amongst us that the
gentiles by my mouth should hear the
word of the gospel
and believe is referring to cornelius
and that he had seen this sheet come
down full of unclean animals and the
jews considered
the gentiles unclean and he was
emphatically commanded not to call that
unclean which god had declared clean
and so he went to cornelius and
cornelius fell at his feet and he said
do it not i'm just a fellow
human being like you are so he wasn't
acting like a pope right
and then he said to cornelius
you know that it is unlawful for me as a
jew
to associate with the gentile but god
has shown me envision
that i should not call any man impure or
unclear
and to which law did he refer
it's unlawful for me to you and that's
part was part of the
ceremonial law and moses is law moses
law
so there was much disputing amongst them
and peter made the speech and by the way
paul was also called to the being the
apostle to the gentiles
but they wouldn't accept his authority
and that issue so they referred it to
the apostles
so after much disputing this is where it
came to
and then they wrote letters by them
after this manner the apostles and
elders and
brethren sent greetings unto the
brethren which
are of the gentiles in antioch and syria
and silicia now
this is how it worked in those days the
authority
lay in a vote of the entire assembly
so who voted the apostles
the elders and the brethren and the
brethren that came together
and they sent greetings unto the
brethren
which are of the gentiles in antioch and
syria and cilicia so there was a
conference and the brethren as a unit
decided now of course if you have a new
translation
they will put a comma and they'll say
the apostles of
elders and leave that brethren out
and just say they wrote to the brethren
so there you have
a hierarchy but in god's church
everybody is equal for as much as we
have heard
that certain which went out from us have
troubled you with words
subverting your souls saying you must be
circumcised and keep the law
in other words the ceremonial law that
the moses law was still given by god to
moses
absolutely that's why it's important
that you mention the ceremonial
law but the moral law was written on
stone by the finger of god and was
placed
in the ark and the ceremonial law was
hand written by moses and placed beside
the orcs
it seemed good unto us being assembled
with one accord
in other words that's how the vote went
to send chosen men unto you with our
beloved barnabas
and paul now this is interesting they
didn't just go with a letter they sent
witnesses
yeah because the people were so fired up
there was no small contention that they
would probably have
rejected what paul and barnabas said
anyway
so they sent witnesses that it really
was so
now what did they decide
this is now in galatians chapter 2 verse
9 we get a little bit more of an insight
right
when james and kephas and john who seem
to be pillars perceived the grace that
was given
unto me they gave to me
and barnabas the right hand of
fellowship that we should go
unto the heathen and they unto the
circumcision so this is in the early
church when paul
was sent to go and preach to the
gentiles so
they had the blessing of
the chief of the apostles james
kephas which is peter and john john
only they would that we should remember
the poor
the same which i also was forward to do
and then this little world word but
when peter was come to antioch i
withstood him to
the face because he was to be blamed
for before that satan came from
james he did eat with the gentiles
but when they were come he withdrew and
separated himself fearing them which
were of the circumcision
and the other jews dissembled likewise
with him in so much that
barnabas also was carried away with
their dissimulation
what is paul saying here now peter had
just
said that they were of one accord yes
all right they all agreed
okay you don't have to do this thing and
they sent letters and they signed it and
we were a one accord
and james got up at that meeting and he
made a speech
and he was the one that summed it up and
said okay
we won't put all of these restrictions
that the jews had
which neither our fathers or we
could bear and so we admonish you to
abstain from from food that is strangled
from taking blood so he kept the health
laws right
and that this is no longer required of
you
basically it has been fulfilled in
the new testament but then
james who was at that stage the
spokesman
seemed to have had second thoughts and
he had little discussions with
certain men that came from
james and they seemed to have
worked with the mind of peter and so
peter was swayed from his very beautiful
speech that he had made
because before he didn't mind eating
with the gentiles
and now all of a sudden he had a problem
right
and not only that and the other jews
dissembled likewise with him in so much
that even barnabas
who in the beginning was so strong in
arguing against
it was swayed so are these issues
contentious within the church
yes exceedingly
exceedingly so we must be very
careful very circumspect
and we should not allow dissension to
come into our ranks
because of a misunderstanding
or a different interpretation
of an issue our job
is to preach the three angels messages
so let's get back to the feasts
there were seven annual jewish feasts
and they served as a type and an
anti-type
now the type if we go to them
passover what was
the anti-type of the passover it was the
crucifixion
right because they had to take a lamb
without
blemish they had to
in their clan in their family consumed
the
entire lamb it had to be
prepared with bitter herbs
now just just take that as an example
firstly there was no blood in that
animal because the blood was completely
washed out
because blood was forbidden they
they were even so strict that they they
washed it out with salt water
so it was an extremely bland
product and then it was prepared with
bitter herbs
so it was not something that you
relished
not not some like nice bbq barbecue or
a spit you know no no no no it was not
something that you relished
and it was probably a smallish lamb
and the whole family now the family
included the whole extended family
and if there were not enough of them
you could take others in
with the party so each one had a piece
and it had to be consumed
the typology is very interesting if you
want to internalize christ
in other words the character of christ
how much of him do you want to
internalize
all of him all of it that was the
symbolism
but because one man couldn't consume it
all it was
spread over the entire clan of the
entire family
and it was a better morsel
now when you change your
your lifestyle when you change your view
when you become a christian
out of a worldly situation
that is a better draft to drink yes but
you have to drink it
you have to drink that cup to the dregs
and then it becomes sweet in your
stomach
right in your stomach but still the walk
is quite bitter absolutely so
the passover and this feast that took
place on that day
was a type of the crucifixion
now the anti-type the crucifixion is of
course greater than the type which was
just the shadow pointing
towards it so when christ was crucified
what point was there in keeping the
passover
yeah that is
fulfilled and then it is fulfilled now
some
people say it was not fulfilled the
early church
there is a good record that they still
took part in the festivals but they were
still arguing about
many many issues and as the knowledge
of the typology unfolded
they changed over time yes
the next feast was the feast of
unleavened bread this was the very next
day nisan 15
and the body that was broken
this bread said jesus symbolizes my body
right that was broken for you
and that symbolizes christ in the grave
this sinless one became sin for us
so was christ
in the grave fulfilling the type
of unleavened bread yes yes
the next feast was the next day so that
was
the feast of first fruits and that
typified the resurrection
so you had feast and you had the
anti-type
feast and the anti-type feast
and the anti-type then you had the feast
of weeks
now that was sivan six and that
typified pentecost now
pentecost is when people were empowered
to preach christ in other words the holy
spirit was poured out
to empower the disciples of christ
to preach the gospel that's why it was
porter
plus all the other functions of the holy
spirit of course
but the outpouring was to preach the
gospel
the holy spirit had always been there
before
and he convicted of sin and
righteousness
and justice and all of these issues
and led you to the word but pentecost
was an
outpouring to preach christ right
now my question to you is
did that happen only once and never
thereafter
no or is the holy spirit constantly
being poured out in the gospel
preached to every single generation yes
can i therefore keep one day
when pentecost has already taken place
and has
become a continuum no that will make
null and void the the gospel conversion
okay so now uh here's the problem
if the feast is absolutely essential
do i then have to wait for that
particular day to have an experience
with the holy spirit
it's just a question i'm asking i'm not
being vindictive i'm just
asking the question let's carry on
then there was the feast of trumpets
now this heralded the judgment
that's what the trumpets were there for
and this was tishri one so this heralded
the second advent movement
has that taken place already yes yes
and then there was the day of atonement
one of the most important days on the
calendar
and it prefigured the pre-advent
judgment
so the day of atonement was a day
in which you afflicted your soul
and made right what was
wrong and came into harmony with god
because judgment was at hand
and christ already announced that
judgment had come
when he'd come to the earth yes
and then finally you have the feast of
tabernacles which is homegoing
or the second advent so theoretically
you could say
that the feast of tabernacles is
not yet fulfilled because we haven't
gone home yet
but if you accept that christ has
promised
that he would come again that he would
prepare a place
then when you accept christ don't you
believe
that you will be going home with him so
by faith it has already been
fulfilled well is the feast of
tabernacles only when the second coming
comes or is it also in waiting for it
yes you are waiting so we are in the
feast of tabernacles continually
and in a sense within the adventist
church at least we used to have
before the lockdown something called
camp meetings
which were almost a type of a feast of
tabernacles
you tabernacle together
and you bathed yourself in the knowledge
that christ was going to come and take
you home
soon now why is it
that of late there is this massive
movement to bring the feasts back
where did it start because
if you go through the history of the
church
the early church had some
relics of it then it disappeared
completely yeah
the reformation never
brought it up so it's a new thing that
the feasts must now be kept again right
so where did this actually start
well you can go back to vatican 2 and
the jewish question
this is interesting so the existing
links between the christian liturgy and
the
jewish liturgy will be born in mind
so said vatican too
to improve jewish christian relations
it's important to take cognizance
of those common elements of the
liturgical life
formulas feasts rites
etc in which the bible holds an
essential place
so where does this come from this comes
from the documents of vatican
ii austin p flannery
page 743 so this this is a
vatican ii decision that to find common
ground between christianity and judaism
we need to reactivate the feasts
vatican ii document page 744
christians must therefore strive to
acquire a better knowledge of the basic
components of the religious tradition of
judaism
they must strive to learn by what
essential trace the jews define
themselves in the light of their
own religious experience
so what the early council said the
gentiles did not have to
concern themselves with the vatican ii
council decided you have to concern
yourself with
and we always have this whenever
whenever the bible says one thing
rome says another we're quite used to
that right now
let's read on this is
vatican 2 document page 747 the history
of judaism
did not end with the destruction of
jerusalem
but rather went on to develop a
religious tradition
and although we believe that the
importance and meaning of that tradition
was deeply affected by the coming of
christ
it is still nonetheless rich in
religious values
now that might be true that it had
or has to them religious values but does
it mean that they have to be applied to
the christian today
no this is not necessarily right
research into the problems bearing on
judaism and the jewish christian
relations will be encouraged among
specialists
so that's interesting you have to be a
specialist in order
to make this comparison and then i guess
the specialist is the one that tells you
what you have to do
right correct does the bible work like
that
i i have never read that the bible says
that the bible says that you must study
for yourselves and then you make the
decision right
here you have a coach and he's going to
tell you what to do
okay wherever possible chairs
of jewish studies will be created and
collaboration with
jewish scholars encouraged so this is
something that they want to permeate
through the whole of christianity
and it comes from vatican ii
well when that happens then my antennas
go up hebrews 8
13 and that he says a new covenant he
has made the
first old now that which decayeth and
waxes old is ready to vanish away
so clearly the bible teaches
that certain portions of the old
covenant
are no longer applicable that's what the
bible teaches
rome says it's an important tradition
therefore you will keep it
i've come to almost believe that
whenever rome
says something the opposite is true
almost yeah
almost and
another thing that a lot of people now
do is with
this waxing old part of the old covenant
they
throw in the sabbath but we've discussed
that many times the sabbath
is part of the moral law and it's the
heart of the moral law
it is not part of the ceremonial law
although
it is included and the feast days are
called
ceremonial sabbaths yes and according to
colossians which we dealt with in a
previous one
those have been removed they've been
nailed to the cross
in other words they're obsolete the
ceremonial sabbath
now remember the feasts always were
associated with sacrifices yes
sacrificial systems now if you do make a
sacrifice
then you are actually denying that the
anti-typical lamb has been sacrificed
because then you are using a type
so if you want to remove the sacrificial
system
you've actually taken the heart out of
the feast yes
there's no point there is no point to
keep on holding a day
that you if you don't have any sacrifice
on it exactly
but what about the sacrifices that were
done
daily yeah there was also on the sabbath
absolutely so this this fact that jesus
was going to die with you
was such an important component that
there was a morning and an evening
sacrifice daily which also took place on
the sabbath
but the sacrificial system came to an
end
which means the sacrificial system on
the sabbath also came to an
end so that is
was created for a different reason
it's not for the antitypical um creation
to show towards jesus exactly so the
sabbath pointed back to creation
remember the sabbath because in six days
the lord made the heavens the earth and
the springs of water right
it pointed backwards to creation the
ceremonial sabbaths pointed
forward to christ the reality being
christ
so what does ephesians tell us about
this ephesians chapter 2 verse 14
for he is our peace who has made
both one and has broken down the middle
wall of partition
between us talking about the jews and
the gentiles
having abolished in his flesh the
enmity even the law of commandments
contained
in ordinances that is the law of moses
that's what it was called it was the
written the handwriting
of moses for to make in himself
of twain one new man so making peace
so according to this verse the
handwriting of ordinances
which is the ceremonial law was removed
so which laws still pertain
to us number one the moral
that's written in stone you don't touch
it you don't add to it you don't take
away for it
it stands forever
who interprets that law god does the jew
says you were breaking the sabbath by
healing a man he said no i'm lord of the
sabbath i'll tell you how it is kept
correct he didn't break it no he never
broke
the sabbath no he only broke the sabbath
according to the jews exhibition
and their laws he is the lord of the
sabbath he'll tell you what the meaning
of the sabbath that doesn't mean
that like many people want to allure
that
because he's lord of the sabbath he
could break it exactly
that's not that doesn't work that's that
is not the character of god
the law is a transcript of his character
and thank god it is a transcript of his
character
and that he might reconcile both unto
god in one body by the cross having
slain
the enmity thereby the ceremonial law
was placed besides the ark as a
testimony against you
the moral law told you what sin was
yes so when you looked in the mirror you
saw that you were a sinner
but the ceremonial law actually said to
you you are responsible for the death of
the lamb
that's against you and god
took that upon himself and became that
antitypical lamb
and took my guilt and my sin upon him
which
is absolutely astounding the
ceremonial law could not set you free no
only god could do that that's why jesus
had to die
yes and the ceremonial law was called
the shadow
because the substance was christ but
keeping the moral law
can set you free okay can i hit you with
my shadow
no no but i can with my hand right
okay so this is what it clearly says the
handwriting of
ordinances or the commandments contained
in ordinances
exactly the same thing whether you're
referring to colossians or ephesians
it's
talking about the ceremonial law
so if we go to colossians it says
blotting out the handwriting of
ordinances which is the same thing
ceremonial law that was against us
we've just explained that why it was
against us
which was contrary to us and took it out
of the way nailing it to the cross
and having spoiled principalities and
powers he made a show of them openly
triumphing over them in it
and then this verse that always creates
problems let no man therefore
judge you in meat or in drink or in
respect
of a holy day the greek there
is orto's feast day or festival
or of a new moon or of the sabbath days
plural
now all of these feast days were also
ceremonial
sabbath days and they
were nailed to the cross which are a
shadow of things to come but the body
is of christ so they were a shadow
pointing to jesus christ so that no one
judge you
in meat that is food that's
old english that doesn't me if it was
meat like we say today it would say
flesh
right so the king james talks about
an animal tissue as flesh and meat
is food food or drink
now does the sabbath contain anything
about eating and drinking
no no it's a reminder of where you come
from yes
to the ceremonial laws contain eating
and drinking yes
absolutely so in other words let no one
judge you
in eating or drinking all the feast days
all the new moons all the sadder and
sabbath days plural
yes the new moons also determine the
feast days
yes now if you have a new translation
they
violate this verse and they make that
sabbath day with the capital s
and therefore actually
include the moral law correct so the new
translations
based on the alexandrian texts
are in my opinion in this verse
nothing short of diabolical
they are a shadow of things to come they
are a type
pointing to the great anti-type and
according to this
they no longer apply
now let's take a look at what the spirit
of prophecy says in the desire of ages
we have a very
interesting section it says
there on page 652-653 the following
christ was standing at the point of
transition
between two economies
and their two great festivals
so now she's only talking about two
but it's about the feasts right
he the spotless lamb of god was about to
present himself as a sin offering
that he would thus bring to an end the
system of types and ceremonies that for
four thousand years had pointed to his
death
bring an end to the system of types and
ceremonies
as he ate the passover with his
disciples
he instituted in its place
the service that was to be the memorial
of his great sacrifice
the national festival of the jews was to
pass
away forever
the service which christ established was
to be observed by his followers in
all lands and through all ages
so she's referring here particularly to
the passover
and in its place he instituted the
communion servant yes
in its place and the first was to
pass away forever if it applies to one
there was typological doesn't apply to
all
yes in my opinion it does in many other
people's opinions
it won't because there was no small
contention between them correct
here's an article in the review and
herald and by the way
people might say but that is ellen white
but what she's saying is
absolutely in harmony with the scripture
in this ordinance the last supper of
communion
christ discharged his disciples from the
cares
and burdens of the ancient jewish
obligations in rites and ceremonies
that's pretty clear isn't it
these no longer possessed any virtue for
type was meeting antitype
in himself what does the catholic church
say
they have a deep tradition and therefore
they are of value today and we'll have
to appoint specialists
to see how we can join these two and
then
have these specialists inform the
churches that they must introduce this
into their religious systems so that we
have commonality with the jews
so that we're going to have commonality
between those that believe
that jesus was the messiah and those
that don't
believe that he was the messiah they're
going to have solidarity
solidarity okay
so let's read that again these no longer
possessed any virtue for type was
meeting anti-type in himself
the authority and foundation of all
jewish ordinances that pointed to him
as the great and only efficacious
offering
for the sins of the world now how many
feasts are included in that statement
i think all of them okay
he gave this simple ordinance that it
might be a special season when he
himself would always be present
to lead all participants in it to feel
the pulse of their own conscience
to awaken them to an understanding of
the lessons
symbolized to revive their memory
to convict of sin and to receive
their penitential repentance
he would teach them that brother is not
to exalt himself above
brother that the dangers of disunion and
strife shall be seen and appreciated
for the health and the holy activity of
the soul
are involved so the foot washing
ceremony
was to remind us that we have to be
in association with humility when we
deal with each other
and this ordinance was the great
reminder
of his great sacrifice now
when the jews brought a lamb it
was the same thing they were to consider
the message
that was embodied in the slaughtering of
the lamb
but it became a ritual to them and blood
flowing was more important later they
wanted to walk
yes they ankle deep in the blood so that
they stopped the drainage and
they stopped the drains where does it
say that in the bible
then ritual becomes important now that's
exactly what rome loves
rome loves ritual
god loves faith
sacrifice and offering you did not
desire
what he wants is humble obedience
but the sacrificial system was given
as a type and a reminder of why
and how sin was to be dealt with
exodus 12 14 and this day shall be
unto you for a memorial and you shall
keep it
a feast to the lord throughout your
generations
you shall keep it a feast by an
ordinance forever
the hebrew is olam annoy us
you shall keep it forever what do you do
with that now
well when you accept
christ and you internalize
the message of the feast then you
are keeping it forever that he is the
lamb of god that was sacrificed for your
sins
and in the ordinance that was put
in its place you continue to be reminded
of it
so let's put it this way the feast isn't
actually gone
it's been incorporated and swallowed up
that's why jesus said he came to fulfill
it he didn't come to say
it wasn't worth anything or something
absolutely not he came and said
i am now the full embodiment of this
yes and because they made the ritual if
you read isaiah
he says that your feasts are abhorrent
to me
exodus 12 17 and ye
shall observe the feast of unleavened
bread
for in this self-same day have i brought
your armies out of the land of
egypt therefore shall you observe this
day in your generations by an ordinance
forever
what does the unleavened bread point to
also to the sinlessness of jesus yes he
said this is my body that was given unto
you it was broken for you
now when you say when you take part in
the communion service
do you not remember this it is embodied
it has been let's use the word absorbed
into that which has put been put in the
place thereof
now when jesus said your house
has been left to you desolate
that means empty empty and the
sacrificial system was taken away
completely right and for 2 000 years
almost
it's gone yeah so
for 2000 years there's been no
sacrificial system now they want to
revive it
if they revive it what are they saying
that
jesus didn't come exactly
this ordinance does not speak so largely
to man's intellectual capacity
as to his heart talking about the
communion
his moral and spiritual nature needs it
if his disciples had not needed this it
would not have been left for them as
christ's
last established ordinance in connection
with and including the last supper
it was christ's desire to leave his
disciples and
ordinance that would do for them the
very thing they needed
that would serve listen carefully to
disentangle them
from the rights and ceremonies which
they had hitherto
engaged in as essential
and which the reception of the gospel
made
no longer of any force
to continue these rites would be an
insult to jehovah is that pretty clear
yes now again people will say but this
is
alawite but is it in harmony with
scripture
yes eating of the body and drinking of
the blood of christ
not merely at the sacramental service
but daily partaking of the bread of life
to satisfy the soul's hunger
would be in receiving his word and doing
his will
that is why the circumcision
was taken away from a literal
circumcision
to a circumcision of the heart
there had to be a shift from ritual
to inner understanding and acceptance
this is the only offering that is
acceptable to god
and that is why the early church decided
that it was no longer necessary to
circumcise
well would it be for us to have a feast
of tabernacles
now we spoke about that one right and
said that doesn't seem to be fulfilled
so let's just read what it says here
it's very interesting comes from the
review in herald
november 17 1885
a joyous commemoration of the blessings
of god to us
as a people as the children of israel
israel
celebrated the deliverance that god
wrought for their fathers
and his miraculous preservation of them
during their journeyings from
egypt to the promised land so should the
people of god
at the present time gratefully called to
mind
the various ways he has devised
to bring them out from the world out
from the darkness of error
into the precious light of truth we
should often
so do we have a ritual feast here that
is repeated only once a year no no not a
specific date
not a specific time or measured by the
moon or nothing
is there a specific time for the
communion service
no no we should
often bring to remembrance the
dependence upon
god of those who first led out in this
work
we should gratefully regard the old
waymarks and refresh our souls with
memories of the lovingkindness
of our gracious benefactor
so we have also been called out of egypt
we have also been called to tabernacle
and that we do when we come together and
we remember
how god graciously called us
from a life of sin to a life
of walking in harmony with him
we are indeed strangers here in pilgrims
to a better country
our prospective home is the heavenly
canaan
where we shall drink of the pure river
of the water of life
clear as crystal proceeding out of the
throne of god
and of the lamb but as we journey onward
what a blessed privilege is ours
to accept the invitation of christ
if any man thirst let him come unto me
and drink
let us rejoice in the goodness of god
and show forth the praises of him
who has called us out of darkness into
his marvelous light
that is what in my opinion is left
of the feasts thank you very much for
that explanation
i think we can conclude with that for
today
will you close with a for us with the
word of prayer yes
heavenly father there are so many issues
which can cause
contention and i pray lord that you will
bring a sense of unity to your children
wherever they are in the world
help us to concentrate on the essential
things of the gospel for the times that
we are living in
so that we are not sidetracked with all
of these issues
how much work can be left undone
because of contention on issues
where there can be such a diversity of
thought
bless your people and help us to
be good soldiers of christ bringing the
message of salvation
to the world preaching the three angels
the message of warning
and waiting for the soon coming of our
king and savior
this is my prayer in jesus name amen
amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you